[Musique]
sur le bord de la départementale de la
ravine des cabris depuis 28 ans le vieux
domaine est une parcelle le 3 hectares
où se croisent des passionnés de tous
les horizons
lorsqu'on voit donc d'aller faire la
visite directement notamment passé par
là village ça village d'engager malgache
que nous avons retrouvé pourri
complètement là où il était nous avons
restauré
nous avons pas beaucoup de moyens nous
avons réalisé grâce à des bénévoles
c'est l'amant fait du domaine des gens
du quartier qui qui qui ont gravité sur
cette structure là pour mettre en place
tout ce cheminement nous avons fait un
certain nombre d'années un lieu atypique
sur un domaine historique qui reprend
des scènes de la vie longtemps taris com
c'est rapide et bien que nous mêmes
valeurs comme patrimoine ici et notre
travail c'est au monté aux avants très
longtemps mais limitera à haut volume et
mamie trouve dommage qu'un tronc comme
ça les les
les couper tout quoi laisse enfin voila
quand on a quelque chose à dire donc
m'aimerait que l'ue continue dire
quelque chose
l'histoire la botanique ou encore la
culture font ici bon ménage entre le
renouvellement de l'axé routier l'accès
au site par les personnes âgées ou
encore les chantiers d'insertion par
l'activité économique de valorisation de
l'artisanat
la signature de cette convention avec le
département et la commune de
saint-pierre offre d'autres perspectives
à ce pool l'attractivité cette énergie
ne s'est jamais estompé en fait a
toujours été forte quelquefois le corps
ne suivait pas mais le fait d'avoir fait
cette convention c'est un soulagement
même si un engagement physique et voire
même intellectuelle on aura des
personnes qui vont aussi peut-être
orienter différemment nous donner des
idées nous apporter des choses est ce
qu'on va élargir en fait ce plateau qui
va oeuvrer pour l' existence pérenne du
ve domaine
c'est ça le plus important ce que j'en
connais aujourd'hui c'est que le
département travaille en partenariat
avec 1 avec l'écomusée l'ensemble des
communes et en essayant de trouver la
petite pépite qui a au niveau de ces
communes est une des pépites de saint
pierre on ne sait pas où donner de la
tête dans ce lieu magnifique chaque
bénévole de cette association apporte sa
pierre à cet édifice patrimonial cette
pépite du quartier historique de mahavel
à la ravine des cabris à rien prochaine
prochaine
[Musique]